avec nous pour en parler loïc
prud'hommes députés elle est fille de
gironde qui en duplex avec nous bonsoir
loïc prud'hommes sur ce plateau
d'accueil pierre frédéric billets mer et
l'air de dreux bonsoir riblier merci
pierre frédéric billets merci d'être
avec nous la police attaqués dans
plusieurs villes de france on l'a vu
argenteuil cannes c'est pas une première
malheureusement des actes qui vous
inquiète
oui alors moi vous savez que je suis
fonctionnaire du ministère de
l'intérieur à l'origine donc je le
connais bien ces secteurs et surtout de
la police et c'est vrai qu'on voit se
multiplier des attaques contre les
policiers des gendarmes alors avant il y
avait la peur du gendarme
aujourd'hui cette peur commence à
disparaître sérieusement et on
s'interroge sur nos policiers et nos
gendarmes dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions il faut absolument qu'on vous
réitère le soutien envers nos forces de
police et bien rassurer sur la sécurité
qui peuvent avoir dans le cas de leur
métier alors besoin d'être rassurés loïc
prud'hommes vous ça vous inspire quoi
ses attaques ses provocations on en
reparlera justement de ces provocations
mais la police n'est plus en sécurité en
france
je crois que c'est la question de la
sécurité de temps tiers qui est
interrogée aujourd'hui dans votre wii à
notre institution
précisément et je crois que votre
reportage et vos reportages montrent
comment l'amalgamme finale en de
plusieurs faits assez détaché les uns
des autres créer un sentiment qui
finalement peut s'auto alimenter par eux
selon ce que l'on entend ce que l'on
écoute sur les antennes ici ou là
précisément je me permets de réagir
parce que notre débat justement va plus
loin pour essayer de comprendre si c'est
un vrai sentiment voire un fait réel
donc on n'essaye pas de faire des
amalgames attention c'est précisément
l'objet de notre face à face aujourd'hui
d'essayer de comprendre le vrai du faux
j'entends bien mais ceci dit il ya
beaucoup de situations très différentes
qui ont été présentés je pense qu'on ne
peut pas les mettre dans un même analyse
néanmoins je veux juste répondre plus
précisément votre question sur ses se
qualifier sur les policiers
effectivement et je pense que c'est une
problématique il faut pas regarder
uniquement sur ces faits qui sont
gravissimes et que je que je dénonce
cette attaque notamment sur le commune
argenteuil mais néanmoins ça pose une
question plus large le commande est
arrivé à une telle distinction entre la
population de ces quartiers la
population en général en france et est
finalement une sorte de
jeu les dires de
défiance vis-à-vis de la police de la
police et le j'allais dire le fait qu'on
a coupé la police de la population est
un problème qui devrait interroger
d'abord les élus que nous sommes et puis
la police d'une manière générale et les
retraités retrouver ce lien police
population est je pense un axe de
travail qui est essentiel pour pouvoir
trouver des solutions de fond et pas
seulement réagir je veux dire de manière
épidermique en effet ils sont ici ou là
sporadiques et je voudrais pas qu'on
puisse aussi regarder ça de manière plus
générale je pense pas qu'il y ait de
statistiques nous permettent de dire que
finalement de l'insécurité progressé
mais je pense que c'est effectivement
sur le sentiment qu'il faut que l'on
travaille ça vous inspire quoi justement
pierre frédéric biais la réponse parce
que c'est vrai que ce sont souvent de
vision on oppose la vision de la droite
et la vision de la gauche sur ce terrain
là ça sous-entendre et voilà que
quelqu'un mal fait son boulot peut-être
les autorités dans ce lien qui est
distendu entre la population ou la
police il ya de cela ils globalement
c'est un sujet majeur de l'élection
présidentielle 93% des français estime
que c'est un sujet majeur donc il faut
le prendre en considération faut pas
prendre ça d'un revers de la main ce
serait une erreur à mon avis et puis les
français si vous voulez il ya deux
sujets qui les intéressent il ya des
sujets sur lesquels on a sur la police
tout d'abord parce qu'on va justement et
bien sûr sur la police il faut pas avoir
des théories roues à dire qu'on va
désarmer la police quand même pu le lire
jean luc mélenchon c'est pas très
sérieux il ya des préoccupations qui
sont gérés manifeste la violence contre
les personnes
c'est un sujet elle est en progression
depuis des années ça c'est l'insee et
miss ordinateur qui le dit et puis
les vols et les actes d'incivilité qui
sont encore une autre catégorie mais
tous ces événements là effectivement
génère un sentiment d'insécurité mais
qui est pas qu un sentiment qui est une
réalité de terrain les agressions
sexuelles il faut en parler il ya une
augmentation des agressions sexuelles
qu'il est phénoménal qu'est ce qu'il
fait par rapport à ça quand tu auras
pour finir sur les policiers vous rendre
la parole parce que je vois que vous
voulez réagir loïc prudent mais je
voudrais justement vous faire écouter un
policier sous le choc quand c'est ce que
disait gérald en maintenance au matin la
police et est sous le choc et c'était un
soulagement qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
vraie blessés je vous propose donc
l'écouter laurent martin de frémont
secrétaire départemental du syndicat
unité sgp fo police nationale des alpes
maritimes
sachant qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
énormément de comptes à rendre sachant
que nous devons nous justifier pour tous
et pour n'importe quoi et bien les
collègues préfèrent aller vendre des
frites je vous le dis très franchement
et aujourd'hui on se dirige vers des
collègues qui sont au bout du rouleau
parce que le métier devenu un métier
extrêmement difficile loïc prud'hommes
les policiers qui préfèrent aller vendée
des frites on peut considérer qu'ils ne
sont pas entendus ce monsieur poser
aussi la question du contrôle des
policiers qui désormais ce sont un petit
peu voilà observé critiquer votre
sentiment
écoutez c'est bien en main qu'ils soient
observés et de très près puisqu'ils
détiennent la force légitime de l'état
elle ça n'est pas anodin que de tenir ce
ce pouvoir et donc il faut que ce soit
très contrôlé très encadré et bien sûr
que nous devons très vigilants sur ce
qu'ils sont de cette force légitime et
donc là ça pose plutôt la question de la
formation des policiers qu'ils soient
formés affronter les situations qui sont
effectivement difficile mais je pense
qu'elles l'ont toujours été dans toute
l'histoire de la police et que
finalement cette course à l'échalote en
disant voilà sur les cd que vous évoquez
votre invité en plateau sur la question
du dollar on désarmement je pense pas
que armée avoir une course à l'armement
permettent de régler ces problèmes là
mais plutôt effectivement une question
des effectifs de police de commandes ne
lui sont formés comment ils
interviennent en effectif suffisant sur
les situations comment on laissait pas
intervenir sur sur des choses qui ne
sont pas en mesure de régler
permis aux policiers peut-être de sauver
leur vie dans cette affaire à cannes
oui mais il y aura toujours un cas
particulier et sans doute que une arme
létale utiles que d'autres notre type 2
de protection aurait pu également faire
faire cet office donc c'est ce que je
veux dire là aujourd'hui voilà l'armé
table de maxime
malheureusement très très loin de la
réalité de terrain savez les policiers
ils sont ils ont affaire aux pires
voyous qu'on puisse trouver sur sur
l'espace public on se fait agresser au
couteau on se fait agresser au couteau
aux moins deux policiers portait un pont
un gilet pare balles il n'a pas été
blessé en tout cas physiquement là
dessus ils ont pu riposter de manière
proportionnée parce qu'il allait encore
agressé des policiers dire qu'il narre
n'est pas utile c'est je vous dis
monsieur très gentiment vous êtes très
loin des rites et de terrain il faut pas
être dans l'angélisme ces criminels
j'aime les jeux à travers gély défense
que si les anglais il n'y a plus qu'à
inscrire qu'est ce que va devenir de
société et donc ce discours là qui est
assise idéologique je pense que
malheureusement c'est assez violent pour
les policiers qui font bien leur travail
parce que nos policiers sont très bien
formés il faut les défendre il est une
réforme à faire au niveau du gpn je veux
bien l'entendre c'est un débat qu'on
peut avoir mais les policiers qu est ce
qu ils sont courageux et en plus on les
culpabilise quand ils utilisent leurs
armes franchement je pense que c'est
irresponsable
le dit prudhomme on a parlé de cfm
dalton c'est pas qu'on a tellement envie
de leur faire de la pub ici mais enfin
quand même c'est vrai qu'il me semble un
petit peu effrayé la ville de lyon des
rodéos de motos dans le centre-ville
des provocations envers la police
aujourd'hui ils ont grimpé sur le toit
d'une prison le tout relayé allègrement
par les réseaux sociaux qui il a pour le
coup ne pratique aucune censure ils sont
même invités sur des plateaux télé et je
crois bien ce soir c'est populaire
auprès d'une certaine jeunesse de
pardonnez moi l'expression de se payer
du du flic ça nous fait pas peur
voilà en l'occurrence il s'agit pas de
ça ils défient simplement l'ordre et la
loi et donc je comprends pas qu'avec des
mesures je vais dire de tank est donc on
ne puisse pas identifier
ces personnes-là et belfort d'état dans
ce genre de blessés parce que l'inde sur
des choses qui sont effectivement tout à
fait en dehors ce qui est possible et
terminera par la loi je suis pas la
direccte attaque directe de la
population du sahara et pourtant ces
choses-là ne perdure pas et de vous qui
les moyens qui manquent dans kate et là
on a aussi cette problématique du
partage pas la situation
du maire de dreux je pense que la
formation des policiers a été ces
derniers temps et joue pas que ceux qui
ont bénéficié des formations longues pas
très bien formés mais d'un cran ce n'est
pas le cas et puis en plus ils sont
beaucoup occupé dans des tâches
secondaires pour aller chercher la
barrette de shit alors que les moyens
d'investigation leur manque et que c'est
en amont qu'on peut aussi beaucoup
traiter de ce thème aujourd'hui font
beaucoup de vous parler et il semble que
ça se prend à mon sens priori la
priorité des gens les gens ils ont
besoin surtout une sécurité sociale
et pouvoir se déplacer
tranquille ce qu'il faut pas percevoir
ses essais comment les français peuvent
interpréter ce qui se passe vous êtes un
bon français vous travaillez vous êtes
arrêté au bord de la route pour une
annexe i de vitesse ou vous mina monde
vous dit rien et vont à des gens comme
ça qui se permettent de mettre des vies
en danger avec des rodéos et on n'arrive
pas à régler ce problème moi je ne
comprends pas ce que fait l'état
là-dessus
ces gens là c'est une provocation
permanente aux zones et de gens qui
travaillent et le problème que ça pose
c'est que les français raisonnable ne
commence à ne plus croire au système et
c'est là où il ya un danger donc je vis
ça devrait appeler la conscience de tous
les élus les députés les parlementaires
parce que là on a un problème de foncier
foncièrement qui devient grave ici c'est
que les gens ne croient plus au système
et on doit arrêter ces gens doit les
mettre dans un zoo un tribunal est en
prison justement les gens ils ont
beaucoup réagit sur notre compte rt
france sur ce thème de l'insécurité qui
manifestement fait parler un jeu vous
proposera un premier message évite
certains quartiers de peur de me faire
agresser on ne peut plus circuler
librement nous dit elle cuistot cécile
j'ai grandi à huit kilomètres de paris
j'avais dans un lycée parisien en train
chaque jour ce serait impossible
aujourd'hui
dernier message j'ai beaucoup voyagé
l'insécurité en france est trop présente
même dans les petites villes louis
prud'hommes pourquoi et comment vous
expliquez ce tel sentiment d'insécurité
grandissant dans notre pays est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ces messages des
choses qui était possible il ya encore
quelques années ne le sont plus
aujourd'hui c'est un fantasme ou c'est
la réalité pour vous
je reviens du mal à vous dire que c'est
la réalité moi j'habite en banlieue
d'une grande métropole et
je me déplace
de manière j'allais dire aussi est aussi
rassuré que par le passé je n'évite pas
de quartier
n'importe quels quartiers de cette
métropole
néanmoins ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
oublier qu' il ya des problèmes ici ou
là de vols d'agressions
mais je ne pense pas qu'il soit n'est
plus prégnant en est moins prégnante que
auparavant alors tout à l'heure monsieur
le maire disait que sur les agressions
sexuelles et des expos et une explosion
des chiffres extraits je pense qu'il
faut regarder comment ces chiffres sont
construits c'est aussi aujourd'hui que
sur ce type d'agression par exemple et
je m'en réjouis les les personnes
agressées plus facilement
plus réelle de ski de ce qui se passe
dans le pays néanmoins je ne crois pas
qu'on soit dans une espèce de
de flambée de la violence de la sécurité
où on pourrait croire à n'importe quel
de nos petits villages est devenu tel
chicago infréquentable donc il faut
vraiment faire la différence entre la
réalité et la réalité de ce que l'on
pense
être la réalité de nos villes parce
qu'on entend des faits divers qui sont
parfois monté en épingle et puis ce qui
est réellement vécu quotidien les
statistiques qui sont celles qui sont
celles de terrain remonter et des
activités de ces problèmes moi il me
semble que ne faut pas les les minorer
mais il ne faut pas non plus en faire
l'alpha et l'oméga de toutes les
politiques et notamment sur la question
de la présidentielle je pense que c'est
c'est pas la première d insécurité
aujourd'hui néanmoins il faut la traiter
pierre frédéric blaissa c'est vraiment
le grand vent clivage 1 voilà entre
peut-être la france insoumise et la
droite l air mais aussi la droite plus
dur ce sentiment d'insécurité
une réalité est ce que c'est vrai qu'on
va se poser la question ici est ce que
les médias en font trop esponde mais la
loupe sur tout ce qui va pas et donne
justement ce sentiment d'insécurité au
bal mans il ya toujours un effet
médiatique outre au travers d'histoires
un petit peu compliqué ou dur et c'est
tout à fait normal parce que 93% des
français estiment que c'est un sujet
majeur donc il faut en parler après
c'est une réalité parce que les français
ne vivent au quotidien quand vous êtes
en ile de france vous prenez les
transports tous les jours sur des fois
des lignes qui seront pas très
fréquentables vous le vivez en pas
forcément oui il ne refusera
comportement on voit aussi que les
femmes se peut s'habiller différemment
selon le duo ewen bon ça doit nous
interroger aussi bref il ya au delà du
sentiment une réalité qui font prendre
en compte je pense que l'ex
présidentielle c'est une un bon moment
pour mettre ça sur la table il faut
aussi s'interroger sur comment on peut
se réformer pour être plus efficace je
pense qu'effectivement la police peu
évolué et c'est souhaitable et les
autorités judiciaires je pense par
exemple que tout ce qui est
administration pénitentiaire devrait
être rattachée au ministère de
l'intérieur et plus on me sert la
justice parce que on voit bien que
dans les préférences et les arbitrages
dans ce ministère la l'administration
pénitentiaire a été depuis 30 ans
complètement oublié il faut le rattache
émissaire d'intérieur statut d'une
proposition concrète loïc prud'hommes
vous vos propositions à la france
insoumise justement pour améliorer alors
ce sentiment on va l'appeler puisque
pour vous ce n'est pas nécessairement
une réalité puisque à priori c'est tout
de même l'un des enjeux de cette
présidentielle
mais effectivement moi je n'ai jamais
parlé déjà de terreur dont ils la
question d'information et déjà dit mais
il ya la question des effectifs et des
effectifs de proximité quand
effectivement vous faites voler votre
sac à main ou fracturés votre voiture et
que vous voyez que avant que vous ayez
un policier où une policière puisque
venir enregistrer au fait qui puisse
vous recevoir enregistrer votre pain
pour venir constater c'est parfois très
compliqué parce que les moyens font
défaut comme beaucoup de services
publics de proximité qui sont essentiels
pour le vivre ensemble et les services
de police ne font pas exception à sens
et moi de ne pas vous couper mais dans
certaines de vos mails y est elle est
fille on ne veut pas de vidéos caméras
de surveillance par exemple pour traquer
ces ces délinquants quand ils font un
cambriolage par exemple consacré aux
questions parce que statistiquement et
parce que ça a été déjà documentés par
de nombreuses études la
vidéosurveillance qu'on nous vend sous
vidéoprotection n'a pas n'a pas d'effets
venir à priori de sécurité alors vous
avez voilà du coup avoir sur les caméras
de surveillance l'avis des hobbies des
dalton qu'ils font les imbéciles à lyon
et finalement
pour comprendre la situation à dreux il
ya 25 ans on était on a l'élégance
importante et en 25 ans grâce à la
vidéoprotection et aux efforts communs
de la collectivité de l'état on a réduit
de 40% délinquance alors qu'elle
augmentait sur le territoire national
10% ça c'est des chiffres on n'a
quasiment plus de braquage à dreux 1 1
l'an dernier parce que et la vidéo
protection comme insécurisés les voyous
c'est ça la réalité de vidéoprotection
c'est pas contre les gens c'est pour
protéger pour te protéger les gens
honnêtes
j'ai pas dit que c'était entre les
genres monsieur le maire g 18e en ce
sens ce sens vos protégés par la
vidéoprotection et j'imagine pour perry
vous n'avez pas mis que des caméras si
les états crise il y avait des gens qui
font leur travail de terrain parce que
c'est là que qu'elle est aussi la clé du
succès
merci en tout cas à tous les deux on
arrive à la fin de notre face à face aux
prud'hommes merci d'avoir été avec nous
pierre fresnay billet vers nice à vous
également